notre première crise de gouvernance dans
le dans les temps modernes elle remonte
à la Coupe du Monde
2010 ou peut-être certains d'entre vous
se souviennent que nos joueurs avaient
à la phase du monde refusait de
descendre d'un bus ce qui avait créé non
seulement un trouble sportif mais un une
dégradation de l'image de la France
compte tenu de la répercussion
médiatique d'une coupe du monde de
football et parmi les causes évoquées à
ce moment-là ont été mis en avant la
question de la gouvernance de la
Fédération Française football qui
n'aurait plus correspondu à
nécessité aux obligations d'une grande
fédération en charge de budget important
dans un sport regroupant plus de 2
millions de licenciés et ayant une
résonance internationale importante
et comme c'est parfois le cas à l'issue
de cette crise sportive c'est
enclencher une crise de gouvernance qui
a été qui a fait l'objet de la réunion
d'État généraux et donc l'ensemble des
représentants du football ce sont réunis
pour pouvoir déterminer qu'elle pourrait
être la meilleure gouvernance pour
éviter à l'avenir ce type de crise et
à cette occasion là il est sorti donc
une nouvelle gouvernance de la
Fédération française de football qui
reposait sur un certain nombre de grands
axes le premier axe c'était un exécutif
resserré puisque la précédente
gouvernance on avait entre 20 et 30
membres dans le comité exécutif et donc
l'idée avait été de dire il faut
resserrer l'exécutif de la Fédération
parce qu'on le resserrant on a plus de
chance d'avoir une plus grande agilité
une plus grande efficacité dans
l'exécutif de la fédération
deuxième point important on avait mis en
place un scrutin de liste
un scrutin de liste pourquoi parce que
c'était
la partait de la philosophie qu'une
liste c'est une tête de liste qui est le
leader mais que avec sa liste il
constitue une équipe et que cette équipe
allait porteuse d'un programme et donc à
travers cette tête de liste cette équipe
et ce programme l'idée était d'avoir une
cohérence
dans l'action fédérale donc un exécutif
resserré une équipe un programme et donc
une plus grande agilité et une cohérence
dans la direction de la fédération
c'est ce qui s'est mis en place en 2011
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et force cette constater que la mise en
place de dispositif a eu des résultats
probants sur la durée
probant parce que
vous avez bien voulu faire état des
résultats sportifs des équipes
nationales françaises elles sont je peux
le dire quelque part un âge d'or du
football français
7 tournois finaux mondiaux 4 fois la
France présence présente dans la finale
deux fois vainqueur
j'ai un âge qui me permet de dire qu'il
fut des époques où la question n'était
pas de savoir si on en a la finale
c'était de savoir si on allait au
tournoi final et donc de ce point de vue
là un progrès incontestable du côté des
féminines euro en Angleterre notre
équipe féminine demi-finaliste de l'euro
et je pourrais évoquer les résultats des
équipes de jeunes et donc la France de
ce point de vue là et se pense que c'est
la mission de la Fédération c'est de
permettre à ces équipes à tous les
niveaux d'être les plus performants
possible je pense que les résultats ont
été probants